thank you morning
so as many of you know I'm a huge
advocate for running I think that
running is something it's a kind of
fundamental human movement that all of
us should do whether you're interested
in becoming a better Runner or not is
beside the point running is just really
good for your biomechanics it boosts
your cardiovascular health it's good for
your mental health it's just a great
activity all round but the problem is a
lot of people don't like running and I
think a lot of the issues that people
have with running come from the way they
run coming outside to a trail somewhere
far more Scenic and interesting not only
will make running much healthier for you
in a number of ways that we're about to
discuss but also just make it more fun
more enjoyable and something that you
might actually want to stick to doing
so that's why I think trail running is
something that everybody should at least
try and yes I mean especially you Billy
so let's start with the most obvious bit
shall we what is trail running and how
do you get started well essentially
trail running is exactly what it sounds
like it's running
but on a trail and by Trail we mean
off-road off tarmac off pavement whether
that's a hiking trail whether it's a
cycling Trail whether it's along the
beach whether it's through the woods or
through the hills and then you're just
going to run there just like you would
run anywhere else and that's it that's
trail running now of course like I say
there are some fundamental differences
when it comes to running on a trail
versus the pavement and that's why this
video exists but essentially that's all
you need to know and what you'll find
instantly when you start doing this is
that there's just so much more enjoyable
because you have so much more
interesting scenery to look at it puts
you in an even better mental state and
you know if you're running for mental
health benefits then how better to
Compound on that by choosing somewhere
that's truly Scenic you've got more
things to look at you can explore at the
same time as running instead of setting
a destination just go somewhere like
this find a new Trail and run on it and
that way you're kind of adventuring at
the same time as running and for me and
many other people it just makes what
could otherwise be a fairly activity
around your same block every day into
something more exciting now the first
issue that some people are going to run
into of course is that they don't have
any suitable Trails they don't have
anywhere where they think they can run
lots of people comment on my videos
saying you're so lucky to live in such a
beautiful area man and yeah of course I
am and I don't take it for granted
Oxfordshire is beautiful I'm right near
the chiltons and the Cotswolds and yeah
there's loads of fantastic places to
come but this isn't on my doorstep this
is watlington Hill you've been here with
me before it's stunning but it's a 30
minute drive so if I want to run here I
do need to go out my way I've got some
other places they're a bit more local
like Stoke Woods that's a 10 minute
drive but I can even just go to a park
or a Big Field
so the difference here is that with
jogging you can just run outside your
door with trail running you might well
need to drive to a place to do some
running but if you would drive to your
gym for a workout then driving to a
beautiful spot to do some running or
some hiking it's really no different how
do you find these places well there are
organizations there are hiking
organizations that you can look into
find the routes that they recommend for
me personally I just tend to Google
places near me and often if you Google
one nice place to run or walk if you
find one good place then you'll often
see that it recommends other similar
places nearby so that's a great way to
find them but yeah the only thing I
would say is really fundamental to think
about is your Footwear now you can just
go out trail running in regular trainers
and you'll probably be fine but you are
much more likely to sprain an ankle to
twist an ankle to hurt yourself because
those big shoes with the big soles
they're not well designed to fit into
the grooves that you're going to
encounter on a trail things like roots
and divots in the ground little ditches
personally and you know where I'm going
with this if you watch my videos
regularly I recommend barefoot shoes
barefoot shoes and trail running are a
match made in heaven they essentially
mimic the way that you would run you
know in nature in the wild and I know
that that's a bit of an overdone conceit
but it is true your feet are these
incredible Feats uh pardon the pun of
engineering and when they use them
properly your toes will splay out in
order to cover the most surface area and
in order to fill in the gaps and Contour
to the ground you have tons of
proprioceptors in your feet that provide
you with feedback and allow your body to
tap into natural reflexes that help to
stabilize you and prevent you from
falling if you want to see more on this
then check out my video on barefoot
shoes but it goes super deep
and that of course brings me to today's
sponsor which is once again Vivo
barefoot Vivo Barefoot make in my
opinion some of the very best barefoot
shoes barefoot shoes in general I'm
entirely on board with I think they're
fantastic so they're already on to a
winner but Vivo Barefoot then back this
up with incredibly high quality
production and a great fit a fantastic
range I find that with a lot of shoes
when you get home after a long day the
first thing you want to do is take your
shoes off genuinely with Viva barefoot
shoes I don't feel that way they feel
like slippers and I don't particularly
want to take them off they made in a
sustainable manner too which in my
opinion is a massive bonus and they look
cool you can wear them in a smart
setting you can wear them in the gym you
can wear them for a run today I'm
wearing the Hydra ESC swim run shoes
which were kindly sent to me these are
perfect for trail running they have the
lugs which are an important thing to
look for in any trail running shoe
because they allow you to grip onto
those slippy muddy surfaces and at the
same time they're designed to let you
run easily through water and they dry
out really quickly stay light when wet
so you can get that natural feeling but
at the same time not worry about
drenching your shoes so yeah if you want
to find a good pair of shoes to get
started with then I highly recommend
Vivo bear but click the link below if
you're interested and use the discount
code bioneer 15 to get 15 off your order
thanks again to Vivo Barefoot for
sponsoring this video and now on with
the show however the case you want to
make sure you're looking for shoes that
are either waterproof or that dry
quickly and won't get heavy and Soggy
when you run through water at the same
time you want something with nice big
lugs that are going to grip onto the
ground because sometimes trail running
is going to involve running through
thick mud or water and yeah you'd only
be slipping and sliding around all over
the place
either way whether you go for barefoot
shoes or not I also recommend that you
ease into this because particularly in
barefoot shoes but whatever the case
you're going to find that your ankles
and your feet probably aren't used to
the kind of feedback you're getting from
the ground you're going to be constantly
trying to balance yourself on your
ankles as your feet twist and change
direction you're not just running on a
flat surface and this can come as a bit
of a shot last year I went for a run and
it was extremely icy and I was running
in these big tracks that had been left
by a tractor but then frozen over and
the next day my ankles were so sore
because it was like a big workout and
that was okay because it's something I
was used to but if you weren't used to
this that could easily lead to an injury
that would result in some downtime for
you so yeah you want to ease into this
and certainly always ease into the
barefoot shoes as well because that goes
double when you're wearing those and you
have less support and that's the other
thing to at least be aware of when it
comes to trail running you're going to
be running on surfaces that make it a
lot more difficult like I say if you're
running in a load of mud if you're going
to be slipping and sliding everywhere
you're gonna have to concentrate much
more on what you're doing and of course
it's going to slow you down and be more
of a workout and so of course if you're
someone who runs regularly and you're
used to running at a certain Pace this
can come as a bit of a shock as you find
you're much slower and you're not able
to get usual times that's normal because
this isn't just running in a straight
line on a flat surface you're working
much harder and you can't even compare
your time on one trail run to your time
on another trail run necessarily for the
same reason because if one's got a lot
more elevation or if one's a lot
slippier then you're obviously going to
be slower versus one that's a bit calmer
and easier so yeah don't be too wed to
going fast and that's actually one of
the things I like about trail running
because it forces you to forget running
for numbers and to instead enjoy the
process of running and the health
benefits that come from running whatever
the speed and whatever the case so you
can this way just much more relax let go
and just enjoy the feeling of running
and exploring your environment and what
I also like to do when I'm trial running
is to stop to balance on logs to do
pull-ups on trees to do dive rolls to do
handstands or whatever else and that's
again one of the great things about
running in the woods because you can't
really do all those things in the town
or the city where you live because
you'll probably get run over and as I've
discussed in a recent short you do get
some strange looks
and I love as well always to run without
necessarily having a set destination in
mind I'll have to just pick a spot go
for a run because that way I get to
explore somewhere new and find something
new I discover new things about where I
live I discover new cool places to visit
and it's just much more enriching and
exciting and interesting and to me it's
a bit like playing an open world
computer game it's a bit like playing
sonic Frontiers but in real life you
know you have adventure and excitement
and discovery not just the same Bland
boring route going past that you see
every day on your way to work anyways
but I'm probably most interested in the
benefits it can offer for things like
General performance and the way that you
move and Run and Jump you need to really
focus on your proprioception you need to
constantly adjust your balance and your
angle and yeah it just makes sense if
you're constantly adjusting your feet
angles to different surfaces you can get
better at doing that and the chances of
you slipping over when you're running
outside are going to be minimized your
chances of being able to create a stable
grounded base when you're pushing
something or lifting something or
wrestling with someone or throwing a
kick are going to be greatly enhanced
viewers will know that I'm a big fan of
the work of Nicola Bernstein I love the
idea of repetition without repetition
that means performing the same movement
but in different situations so in this
case we're running but not just on the
same flat ground we're running on lots
of different surfaces and this can help
us to build more robust movement
patterns so that we have more solutions
to draw from otherwise you're going to
get really good at doing the thing you
do with a nice sterile setting of the
gym or the pavement but when you take
that into a more and predictable and
chaotic environment you're not going to
be ready for it and I think one of the
best ways to keep improving anything is
to keep providing the body with novel
stimuli so it's constantly adapting
constantly learning and you're ready
therefore for more scenarios and of
course when you're traveling you're
going uphill more often downhill more
often you're running through thicker
surfaces that simply means you're going
to be using more muscle power you're
either going to be improving your
Mobility running uphill for example
requires a certain amount of
dorsiflexion you're going to be taking
your calves to a greater range of motion
you'll even be engaging smaller muscles
that play important roles like the
tibialis anterior as you're running up
and downhill you'll be moving in the
frontal plane as you move side to side
around obstacles around ditches Etc and
trees something that is very much
missing from a lot of our training
because we just tend to run forwards
especially if you always run on a
treadmill for all these reasons you're
just building a far more Dynamic
powerful and performant body when you
run in unpredictable situations and the
fact that it happens to be so much more
fun so much more interesting I think
everybody should try trail running
so what do you guys think am I over
hyping the benefits of trail running or
is this something that you guys do as
well that you recommend and enjoy is it
something going to start doing now and
what kind of spots do you enjoy trail
running in if you enjoy this kind of
training that looks outside the box and
considers different aspects of human
performance Beyond just the basics of
cardio weight loss and some strength
gains on certain lifts you might enjoy
my ebook and training program super
functional trading 2.0 the protein
performance system that comes with an 80
plus page ebook and over two hours of
instructional video if that sounds
interesting then there's a link in
description down below either way thank
you so much for watching this one guys
and I'll see you next time bye for now